December is upon us and we have a new
BTW a calendar so for the past couple
months have been testing a new BTW a
calendar system and a number dupe and
helping me out beta testing it i went
from 10 beta testers to 20 beta testers
and we finally have something that's
ready for everybody to consume this is
our december BTW a calendar and the idea
here is one to help you keep track of
your bt a number i know that was
something that I'll number of you were
complaining about trying to figure out
how to keep track of it but also to to
try to help you stay on top of your
goals and your daily habits what I found
I've talked about this before is that
when you start your day with something
that you're supposed to do you're much
more likely to follow through on
everything else that you're going to do
for that day where if you start your day
and you forget or too lazy or too tired
to do that first thing that you're
supposed to do your rest of the day is
likely going to fall off track and so
I'm hoping that this becomes a lightning
rod for you to be able to achieve the
goals and the habits that you set for
yourself on a daily basis so it's going
to have a place on my wall soon and I'm
going to let you guys download it you
can go to Evan Carmichael calm / BTW a
doc PDF with the BTA and capitals hope
you guys enjoy it let me know what you
think download away leave a comment
below continue to believe and I'll see
you soon